Dumbledore is a proud member of the LGBT
community as you may not be aware he is
not allowed to be his true self in China
did you see this no let me tell you so
references to a gay relationship were
edited out of Fantastic Beasts the
secrets of Dumbledore by Warner Brothers
for the film's release in China how gay
was Dumbledore in six seconds of
dialogue dialogue it's not a full
frontal scene come on it's a film for
children the point just being that
Hollywood to Florida is we say gay but
Hollywood to China is we'll say whatever
you want please take our money beautiful
isn't it the way in which these sorts of
entertainment honchos and so on their
idea of Bravery is poking at empty
Hornet's nests and whenever they find a
real hornlessness they just randomly
miles it's just completely typical the
same people who have a meltdown about
that happening and attack Florida will
be totally silent when the Communist
Party China expects different roles
that's one of the ways in which the 21st
century could go there's of course of
course we don't update you sir